نشاهد هذه الصور المباشره لطائره ترامب
التي توجهت انطلقت من فلوريدا الى نيويورك
قبل توجيه الاتهام له حسب ما هو مقرر يا
طاهر والتهمه بطبيعه الحال هي دفع رشوه
لشراء صمت احدى النجمات وكان هناك اجراءات
امنيه مشدده تقريبا هاته
اليوم في برج ترامب تمهيدا لمحاكمته غدا
قلنا قبل قليل مع ناديه وطلال بانه
الاجراءات الامنيه مشدده جدا حتى في
المبنى المحكمه تم ايقاف جميع المحاكمات
ومعظم انشطه المحكمه الاخرى قبل الموعد
المقرر لوصوله ايضا من المتوقع ان يكون
هناك احتجاجات في هذه المواقع يعني نتحدث
عن مبنى محكمه منهاتن الجنائيه وايضا حول
برج ترامب حيث سيقيم عندما يصل اذا نشاهد
طائره ترامب تحلق في اجواء نيويورك قبل
هبوطها
صحيح
كان شرطه نيويورك حذرت من اي اعمال شغب
وبانه سيتم محاسبه اي شخص يقوم بهذه اعمال
الشغب في ايضا نذكر المشاهدين طبعا في
مقابل من يقول بانه هذا امر قانوني محض
وصف ما يحدث له بحمله الاضطهاد وان
الهجمات التي استهدفته لم يشهدها اي رئيس
اخر في تاريخ امريكا